this right here is another
sundance 2022 interview for you on the
collider interview youtube channel i
have the team from summering here
hello congratulations
we don't have much time you guys are a
very busy group celebrating an excellent
film so james i'm going to you first
because
this is a sundance interview a lot of
people out there do not know what
summering is just yet so i must give you
synopsis duty can you give everyone a
brief description of your new movie
yeah um thank you um summering is about
four friends who are um on the cusp of
adolescence um and it's the end of
summer and they make a startling
discovery that sort of alters their
lives i mean that's the sort of the very
um
tiny stuff we we play the characters
that are on the cusp of adolescence just
so you know
all right you
yeah i mean the the bigger story i mean
is it is you know it's about parents and
children and um
you know um it's a story about
friendship about fear anxiety hope and
and what it is to live in a world that
feels unstable and full of change
so
i wanted to ask you a little bit about
the weight for this movie because it's
been a little while at this point since
you last wrote and directed a feature
film so why the return to this format
with this particular story
you know i mean
i think having children i mean is like
an answer for so so much of it i mean i
think this story i i wouldn't have
told were i not a parent i think i mean
there's you know i love i love and have
always loved films about about childhood
and friendship and our first brushes
with death and mortality and that sort
of awakening that you have and the way
that children use imagination to process
trauma in a way that's different than um
adulthood but event that adults do but i
mean for me
i think there were just so many
conversations that i began having um
once i became a parent with my three
kids um and especially my daughter um
as we were watching movies reading books
and my daughter would ask me
where are the girls in these stories
where are the girls in these movies
where i'm you know where is like a
version of me and my friends that sort
of in her own way of saying it you know
that it's about our emotional inner
lives and our hopes and dreams and not
just it doesn't just feel like the main
character's sister something like that
so that's where it all sort of came from
i'm sticking to being a cat mom but now
that i have a niece i feel like i'm
getting like a little taste of that and
an extra layer of appreciation in all
movies like this that i see that i know
she will wind up loving
i'm a cat i'm a cat i'm a cat dad so i
can relate
so like i can kind of give you a
somewhat similar question so
you've been doing a whole lot of really
you know great voice work and series
work the last like i don't know like
four or five years was there a specific
itch to get back into live action
feature films or was joining this
project more about you know the team and
the material
i mean look i think um
you know j i'm i'm a fan of james you
know jay i i this is not only was a fan
of gyms but then also i you know i also
am a mom i don't have a cat i played one
in um
a film but i
i like cats i have nothing against hats
but the point is
i feel like when i read the script i
also felt like gosh i have a daughter i
have a son and equally both through
their their eyes i i want to see female
characters discovering and going on
adventure and and negotiating big world
um
you know feelings and
um concepts
in a way
that
i would have loved to have which is
namely through independent cinema and
like
being able to
forge that kind of um
taste
and um interest from a young age like
that we i don't feel like i had
i mean certainly my kids don't have
access to that kind of stuff and i and
so i i do commend james from that point
of view
in in creating a space to talk about
anxiety about big big you know life
death kind of things but through this
kind of really palatable
um
narrative for for a younger mind and and
yet equally really entertaining for
the whole family you know and that's
that is something that when you do have
kids you're like that's that's currency
right there
you know that's
that we can all watch it and we can all
kind of like have meaningful
conversations after about the human
condition you know
one of the only things i was able to
think of that kind of gave me that as a
kid was now and then so to like after so
many years to see something that finally
taps into that kind of quality is like
it's kind of shocking that it's taken
this long unless there's something out
there that i just haven't discovered
since
yeah i mean you know after this call you
can go and you know if you choose to
have children after this call
um then come back to us in a year and
we'll talk about it and you know
i mean we might be waiting a lot more
than a year but if you guys are patient
fine i'm super patient i mean i'm super
patient right here so he's not patient
there's only one follow-up
there's only one follow-up for uh for
you two ashley and sarah
do you have any cats yes
i have i actually am fostering a kitten
right now that's why i keep putting my
life
running around this room like a [ __ ]
crazy person
a kitten a little baby kitten
yes
um actually after this we have to
sidebar because my my daughter will app
i have to come to your house i need to
come over i'm inviting myself to your
house
i'm looking in together
hello
oh my god you guys
this film is blessed by this kitten
i'm sorry did you say you were fostering
that cat how are you ever going to give
that cat up because my husband is in
love with him so he might stay i mean
let's see
what's his name what's his name the
rescue organization called him little
morris but we call him rocky because he
he um this i'm sorry james i'm hijacking
this
i
grew up with so many cats i could eat
this up okay little rocky was found um
barely breathing because he had been run
over so he had a diaphragmatic hernia so
he had emergency surgery at 10 weeks old
um and they needed a medical foster so i
i flustered him to give him his meds and
help him with his drain um but now he's
like
he's friends i'm going deep in love with
ashley
i'm falling like deeply and madly
especially as she talks about this it's
so calm right now which is so sweet
they want you so lucky to have you
anyway yes i have i like cats have one
okay i feel like any any cat lover i'm a
big fan of so you all you all get credit
right now
um about the movie now ashley uh
for you is making me wonder is there
anything you know i imagine you approach
a project like this and say yeah this
looks like a great film to be a part of
with a great group of people but was
there any reason that it felt like a
good move for you right now something
that it would give you the opportunity
to maybe learn for the first time or try
for the first time
you know i
i always approach everything but based
on the material and the people involved
and you can't do anything other than
that and
this particular script i was really
excited for because i
it kind of reminded me of my youth in a
weird way i grew up in a counselor's day
and our summers were spent always
outside like almost in a council state
it's like you're not allowed inside in
the summer everyone just opens their
door and puts their kids outside in a
way that doesn't happen now i don't
think um so it may be really nostalgic
for that um and i'm getting to that age
now where i get to pay mothers which
i don't know if that should scare me
it's not yet maybe it will give me give
me time if i'm only playing mothers i
might stop depression it but right now
it's attractive to me
sarah brace yourself because i love
talking about first features so much
is this something that just happened to
come your way or were you actively
seeking out opportunities to act in a
film
yeah it's definitely actively seeking it
out um but at the time i you know i
was i was three months into my divorce
um and i got this amazing letter from
james and i just i didn't know i was so
there was so much going on i was i was
displaced from my house and i just i
didn't know but then i got this
opportunity and i just felt
um a connection right away to karna
because she seemed like the type of
person you know not married just wanted
to explore being a mother somehow and so
um
this the closeness that she had with
lola just really connected to that i
don't
have children i did lose my dog in the
divorce so i'm probably the least
maternal person on this call right now
but um i just i just really connected to
the idea of
um
this woman who just wanted to be a
mother and she just did it and she said
you know what i'm i'm going to have lola
and i'm going to have this relationship
with this little girl
and um and then the friendships that she
built with the other girls in the film
and and uh and you know once i got the
letter from james and read the script i
just i really wanted to do it as much as
as crazy as my life was at the time i
really wanted to do it so james you
wrote her a letter what of her past work
gave you that sense that like yes sarah
is the right person for this role and
even though it is a first feature like
i've got faith that you could do it yeah
check that i wrote you james
oh um i mean i'd like to make a joke out
of it but i mean quite i i feel like
sarah helped
me and my wife and our family survive
2020 like coveted year one um like she
like watching her
uh
like embody um um our former president
and sort of um sort of explode him out
from the inside and just sort of um
it just everything that felt like a
collective
like mental health traumatic cultural
gas lighting that was the past several
years and certainly 2020 there was so
much catharsis that i felt through sarah
she made me laugh and feel everything
and i felt like this person who i do not
know i am in an endless debt of
gratitude towards and i want to
watch her in everything and i would kill
to work with her
i love that so much and you're not the
only one out there you had that effect
on quite a few people
um
is there anything sarah that you saw
like ashley or megan do on the set of
this film that you're kind of gonna put
in your back pocket and are eager to try
on a future film um yes everything i
mean
like ashley and all the little girls
tonight i mean all all of them i mean
were inspiring to me i mean
uh ashley and i met up uh friday morning
uh i was shooting on saturday and she
she rehearsed with me she was so sweet i
mean it was just so kind of her to do
that
and um lake had these intense scenes i
mean much more intense than the scenes
that i had and the way that she was able
to just get into that zone i remember
late gave me gave me some great advice
she said if you just want another take
you just ask for another take i never
asked for another take but one day i'm
gonna ask for another take i'm i'm gonna
do it it's not jail you can just like
we're all just human you know it's like
if you want to if you feel it
you're in there you know you know
so it's so hard but to see the thing the
thing that it's just now like coming
alive to me with acting is is
is knowing that each take is going to be
different because you're you're
different from moment to moment you're a
different person and so it's going to be
different and i have this control thing
where i'm like do the same thing exactly
the same way and i i really just
watching them like relax into it and
knowing like whatever happens happens
and whoever i am in that moment is who i
am was just so inspiring for me
so blake and ashley you two both have
tons of experience and i'm sure you know
the young stars in this movie probably
had a whole lot to learn from you but is
there anything that you saw them do even
after all that experience that you know
kind of inspired you to consider or try
something new i think that they i think
that the younger people are naturally
just much more in the moment in a way
that i
think i could benefit from being um and
madeline's like very calm and nothing
really phases her she seems a lot older
than her years and
i don't know if she is nervous but she
never appears to be nervous um and i
yeah i was kind of an aura
i mean you know i really like working
with kids for that reason i think um
you know i've worked with like a lot of
children um i feel like i've been
playing a mom for a while
um or in some way
and i feel
um
part of what i think is so special yes i
would agree with ashley is that they're
very in the moment but then but also i i
think i feel protective you know i i do
feel that sense of
like i got you you know um it's like
when you fly with someone who's like
afraid of flying and even if you're
afraid of flying you have to like kind
of pretend like you're not so that you
can help them out a little bit i mean
that's like my vibe where
when my kids are you know and now of
course my kids are not afraid of flying
and so now i'm like why aren't you you
know but
but the
but i think when you're acting with
someone it is vulnerable and so if
you're in the scene and then you know
the action actions called and i think as
a director i understand that as well you
know like and so i felt a sense of
like maternal
kind of um
protection with leah you know
um
which she didn't need but i think i just
you know i and then and then once i saw
she didn't need it i was like
how can i say something or do something
to kind of
get a reaction
while the camera's rolling you know
um but no she she she was just like she
was very very professional she was
probably more serious than i was i think
james i kind of want to know what you
learned from them too because you've
directed some of the best of the best
over the course of your career but i
guess
depending on what i've seen of yours i
don't think you've ever directed such
young leads before so is there anything
about their approach to the work that
you know illuminated something for you
in terms of your work as an actor's
director that you weren't aware of
before or never even did
yeah i mean for me
so much of directing actors for film and
television is just in casting the right
person you know and it's casting someone
that you find inspiring someone who you
just find interesting whose imagination
you find compelling and i think you know
the sort of the words on the page the
the black on the page is there to be
said but the white space in the script
that is a place for an actor's
imagination to just do with it what they
will and to to expand it it's such a
collaborative medium so i always feel
like once i've you know found an actor
who i really love for a role
they are the character and it becomes
this sort of like falcon mind-meld thing
where i want them to put their
fingerprints all over it i want them to
put their experiences their imagination
their soul into it so yeah with the
younger actors um in the cast
they know so much more about what it is
to be those people than i do um you know
i mean i in developing the script
i have a mom and a sister and a wife and
a daughter and my wife um you know works
at a middle school high school so i'm
around kids that age a lot but again the
lived in experience the authentic
lived-in experience and perspective that
these young actors have is so much more
um
intelligent and specific and
surprising than anything i could bring
so i was constantly deferring to them
asking them would you do this would you
say this how would you say it do i sound
like an old fuddy duddy like whatever
and i found them
sharp and funny and ultimately really um
fearless and inspiring now i have to
follow up for an example is there is
there like a line that felt like old
fuddy duddy and then they changed it and
we can now see it in the final film
i mean i it was like a fun prior to
filming i um did group zooms with the
with the four young actors just trying
to
because because of covid we couldn't
rehearse in person so it was just trying
to create space and time where they
could hang out and i could sort of mute
myself and they could get to know each
other in different time zones in
different countries
um and i would
fall into the role of playing the part
of the old old guy and be like hey
tell me like how much do you use
instagram versus tick tock versus
twitter versus facebook i know i'm like
your grandpa right now but tell me that
thing and i i
i remember i had written the word
youtube star um and um and they
corrected me they're like oh no it's
youtuber and i was like cool
things like that but but actually i mean
that's indicative of actually how they
could
dissect modern culture with a
specificity and like and clarity that i
don't have and i mean in a genuine way
they are aware that their identities
their digital identities are being
commodified monetized like they're being
advertised to they're aware of their
value they're aware of institutional
stagnation in politics
in everything and they just cut through
it like their position on every issue i
found so inspiring and just wise beyond
their gears i feel like i could just
watch a whole documentary about them
expressing their thoughts and opinions
on those matters now yeah i wish i was
on those zooms i would love to hear that
what they
you i thought youtube stars weren't even
a thing anymore like i thought it was
now it's tick-tock youtubers
youtubers youtubers
yeah
tick-tock is the thing apparently yeah
so i'll either watch that documentary or
how about we get a summary sequel and
it's just about the moms hanging out
i mean i i genuinely wouldn't mind that
i lo i love uh i love your young
ensemble here they're all exceptional
but the the way the four of you make the
most out of limited screen time and also
enhance their characters through the
history that they established through
those relationships was
spot on i loved it i have to let you go
big congratulations on summering enjoy
the rest of sundance 2022. thank you so
much